I struggle a lot with being in the
present moment I feel like I'm
experiencing a lot through through my
phone rather than actually being there
like let's take a picture let's film
this let's do this
do MA and then also I just feel like my
mind is so all over the place I'm either
planning and thinking about the future
or I'm remembering the past all the
things I said and did that are horribly
embarrassing and then just cringing
cringing cringing and the result of that
has been a lot of crime like legit
crying I spent the last hour in my room
rolling on the floor and while I was
chasing a cat which is why I was rolling
but just crying and I don't know if it's
pill I don't know why and I've talked
about going to a therapist before and
she's like do you think you're depressed
and I'm always like I don't know and
every week I go in and she asks me what
has been coming up for you what have you
been struggling with what have you been
thinking about and I have the same
answer every week and that's I don't
know I have never felt so out of tune
with my own emotions and I really think
it's starting to stem from not being in
the present and so when I try to reflect
back on what is it I'm feeling what is
it I'm going through I don't know
because I have paid literally no fucking
attention to it I really I just don't
know and I would like to know and I'd
like to figure out what the fuck is
going on and how do you live life and
how do you be happy and how do you not
be so obsessed with this imagined ideal
future and your exaggerated embarrassing
past so that's what's been going on this
week everyone December 12 man future
again I did it stay awesome Gotham